we had to get him on the horn with all
this going on we greatly appreciate the
time in the midst of all the madness
Brian went Horst how are you [ __ ]
what's going on LeBrons mind best you
can tell us we're conversing right now I
think the Lakers are in a great position
with him I think the real question that
he's got to bring himself to this he
willing to go to the Lakers if he
doesn't have another star already there
basically would he trust Magic Johnson
the Laker brand the city of Los Angeles
into getting another star there if he
can get himself comfortable with that
I think the Lakers are in pole position
to do it and while they would love to
have Kawhi Leonard to do to entice him I
also think if you trade the whole roster
to get Kawhi Leonard I'm not sure that
that's a great sign for LeBron I mean
this is a guy who a few you know a few
weeks ago and during the finals was
talking about how yeah if you're going
to beat Golden State you got to beat him
with a front office too so that to me is
the real question and if he's not
comfortable with that
I do think Cleveland is probably running
second and I think Philadelphia is an
option somewhere but I sort of I've been
saying it's like 50 40 10 LA at 50
Cleveland at 40% and Philly 10 ish and
they did 1% other just to protect myself
so who's the other could it be Houston I
mean weren't worse Houston in all this
probably the door is still cracked but
the door pretty much closed this morning
when LeBron opted out Houston really
needs needed to get him to opt in and
try to arrange a trade because now I
mean it's not close you could still do a
sign-and-trade but it just becomes very
complicated so if bran was seriously
considering Houston he probably would
opted into his contract is there a
surprise team there's always a surprise
team and free agency 90% of the time so
I guess I shouldn't use the word always
but is there a possibility of a surprise
team here I don't think so rich because
there's only a couple of places that his
family would want to live you know I
could say Miami to answer your question
but I don't feel that that's going to
happen I also think that again opting
this contract today makes it more
difficult for Miami Miami doesn't have
cap space to trace to to sign him they
would need to arrange a sign-and-trade
it's a little bit more difficult now
that he's opted out but I think it's LA
or Cleveland I respect Philly's
operation I script respect what Billy
has going
I think Philadelphia will get an
opportunity to pitch him either his
agent or him in some way
I think Houston will also get an
opportunity but I don't feel like
they're leaders I feel like it's LA or
Cleveland with LA in the league Brian
went Horst here in the Rich Eisen show
so there's no concern obviously when you
say family where the family wants to
live in Los Angeles's is is a spot where
LeBron already has a home and a home
base etc but there's what about the
concerns of being in the Warriors
division let alone being in their
conference Brian is that a consideration
here with all due respect he's eaten the
Warriors dust ever since the 2016 finals
they beat them on Christmas Day after
the 2016 finals and I think they've lost
like they they beat them one time since
and it's up it's like I think they're 12
and 1 against LeBron and the Cavs it's
not working in Cleveland right now
either so I think if he goes to LA I
think he recognizes that he is probably
not going to beat the Warriors this year
but the future and the upward mobility
of the Lakers is probably better than
the Cavs at this point and that's not an
indictment on the Cavs the reason the
Cavs resources are depleted is because
they've spent the last 4 years winning
championships and competing for
championships the Lakers have spent the
last four years sucking wind
of course the Lakers should have more
assets and more young players to build
from that's not an indictment but it is
the truth and I also think that going to
Los Angeles opens up a lot of other
opportunities for LeBron in the business
world that may soothe the reality that
he may not be on a team it's the best in
his division and you know he in my mind
rich and I do think in his mind too I
don't think he's concerned about his
legacy in his mind it is established
people are going to take potshots
no matter what happened if he had one
more championship or one fewer
championship he would get beginning to
save him on Aflac
I think he's comfortable with where his
legacy is I think you'll see that
comfort play into the way he approaches
the decision Brian went Horst of ESPN
joining us here on the Rich Eisen show
where's Paul George and all this I mean
it's funny at this point last year it
was widely assumed that on this date in
2018 or at least on Sunday's date he
would be a Laker that's why Indiana
flipped him to Oklahoma City and why
Oklahoma City you know ran a risk to to
go and acquire him where where is Paul
George in this whole equation yeah
that's one of the reasons for the
impetus for training for Kawhi Leonard
right now right because assuming that
everything's gonna be a-okay in a year
is maybe a flawed concept you get a guy
as you can all you know I have to
qualify everything rich will have to
excuse this sure I have to qualify
everything because things of the NBA
changed very quickly and and when you
make the Senators statements it opens
the window to you being made an ass out
of yourself but all signs are pointing
to Paul George remaining in LA and I
remain in LA or I'm sorry you're in
Oklahoma City remaining in Oklahoma City
and I'm looking forward to his
explanation for why he would do that to
me you know you a year ago you had Kyrie
Irving raising his hand and saying I
opted out of playing LeBron please send
me out of here and here here Paul George
could sign up to play with LeBron James
in his hometown potentially and he may
be saying I'm gonna stay here in
Oklahoma City I don't I don't know if
that's a referendum on the Warriors or
if that's a referendum on what it's like
to play with LeBron or what it is but
you know if that does come to pass I'd
be interested to hear what Paul George's
rationale is but I might steal for right
now and talking everybody around the
league is that he is going to re-sign in
Oklahoma City the only question is will
he resign for five years which he can do
or he resigned for one or two years so I
look at this conversation could be dated
the second you hang up the phone that's
clearly unjust understood so when when
does Paul George make that decision
today right I mean
to make that announcement about whether
he opts in word doesn't he's already up
he has already opted out
he's already opted out so it's good he's
going he's going to be a free agent but
by opting out in resigning he gets a ten
million dollar raise had he stayed in
his contract right he would make he was
made about 20 million by reciting he
gets 30 million no matter who he signs
with so opting outs a no-brainer that's
a I mean it's a news event because an
action was taken but him opting out
there's not not a comment on Oklahoma
City so then what's the timeframe on
everything here do you think I could see
Paul George agreeing on July 1st or July
2nd and I could see LeBron barring any
sort of major change I could see LeBron
a committing on or around July 4th so
one where you know either LA or
Cleveland and then then the pressures
off of if the Bron comes here and he
signed then the president then the
Lakers obviously would love to add Kawhi
Leonard but then the leverage that the
Spurs have on the Lakers for Kawhi
Leonard right now is we're talking
disappears so when the Spurs Twitter
account wishes Kawhi a'happy birthday as
they did this morning right are they are
they wishing a happy birthday to
inactive my birthday was Sunday so this
is actually a fascinating study in
leverage because Kawhi Leonard will
probably never be more valuable to the
Lakers in a trade scenario than right
now and the the furs know that and the
way the Spurs are looking at it from
what I understand is we're not just
trading you Kawhi Leonard but if we
trade you Kawhi Leonard you're also
going to get LeBron so you have to pay
almost double that you're going to get
two stars because we're gonna have to
live with the fact that we helped to
create a super team in our own
conference so what I think the Spurs are
looking for is a Brooklyn Nets Boston
Celtics s deal from what five six years
ago where they get every young player
and every draft out that's a
we allowed where they asked for the Sun
the Moon the Stars and the Lakers are
like you know what why would we pay you
you know you know this today when we
could get them in a year or if we have
LeBron by next Wednesday you know we
don't we don't have to worry about
drying him and so the Spurs also have to
realize that as you just mentioned rich
that their leverage may dramatically
diminish once LeBron has made a decision
either to stay in Cleveland or come to
LA and now all of a sudden you're you're
you're trying to sell a guy potentially
you only has one year on his contract
and you're not going to get anything
close to the same offer from Boston or
Philly or anybody else so it's a it's a
fascinating study and leverage the only
thing that I think is a factor in this
that is easy to forget is the Spurs
still can offer Kawhi Leonard at 220
million dollar contract nobody else can
offer them that that's almost a quarter
of a billion dollars and they can offer
it to them anytime in the next year and
I don't think there's I promise there's
no trade they can make that will bring
back a Kawhi Leonard so one of the
things that could happen here is if the
leverage doesn't play to their advantage
they always have the fallback option of
trying to work it out and you know that
could be the way that they take and that
could be a reason why they're not going
to going to Bend on wanting everything
from the Lakers coverage all right last
one for you Brian went horse before I
send you into that good day who's the
free agent we're not talking about
because we're talking about all these
shiny objects I mean because there's a
whole ton of free agents coming around
the corner who are we not talking about
that we should be well what here's what
the interesting let's say the Lakers
sign LeBron and they have another
maximum slot space that that Paul George
and nobody else is taking that now is
available somebody can be traded into it
and so the question to me becomes is
there a player out there who's on a team
a star player who's not thrilled with
their situation and may not even it may
not be a free agent who all of a sudden
says you know what now I want to be
trained with a Los Angeles Lakers but
I'm not gonna say any names because I'm
not going out on Twitter I'm not going
to be aggregated off there's no offense
rich but I promise you there are players
out
watching and they're saying hey if bran
is sitting there with no team to play
with can I force my team to trade me and
that's going to be what no one's going
to be talking about because as we saw
last year where Kyrie Irving became one
of the biggest names on the market he
wasn't even on the market until the
third week of July the NBA offseason
never stops and so just because the
Lakers may not get one of the free
agents or get Kawhi Leonard doesn't mean
that if they get LeBron James that when
the ball goes up in October and that
LeBron won't have another storage is on
that team with Bryan loved the chat love
it have a great week next week when
you're so busy crazy busy I'll be out
there watching and we'll chat soon
thanks have a good day you guys Brian
went hoarse the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience